Let's continue our work with functions. There are basic operations we can
perform with functions. We can add them, subtract them, multiply them, and
divide them. We can even do something called the composition of functions, and
we'll look at that later in this lesson. For now let's start with these two
functions: f of x equals 3 x plus 2 and g of x equals x squared minus 1.
Remember that x is the input for our function. It's what we can change, and
input any number in here. F of x is the output for this function. It's the
result that we get when we plug in x. And similarly, g of x is the output for
this function. It's the result we get for whatever number we plug in for x. So,
based on what you know about evaluating functions, what is f of 2? Write that
here. Then what's g of 2? Put that one here. And then use what you know about f
of 2 and g of 2 to figure out this question. What's f plus g of 2? Write that
one here. Now, I know we haven't covered what this means yet, but I think you
can figure it out.